guillaume dustan
comment ça va super je suis pas encore
mort savard est toujours en vie c'est
déjà pas mal ah ouais guillaume dustan
le père de la morandais natasha st-pier
emmanuel philibert de savoie carignan
laurent baffie
voilà guillaume dustan auteurs éditeurs
et vous publiez d'ailleurs chez balland
dans la collection que vous dirigez qui
s'appelle le rayon un livre qui
s'appelle génie diva mais comment on
fait
je comprends pas que dire falco le fasse
et que vous ne fassiez pas il faut
savoir déplaire balladur l'a fait rocard
l'a fait je ne le fais pas raison de
jean paul ii l'a fait non bien croire à
le faire jean-paul à le faire bien sûr
alors
commence très fort votre bouquin
guillaume dustan vous parlez de renaud
camus qu'est cet écrivain qui dans son
journal intime publié chez gallimard
l'année dernière se plaignait qui est
trop de juifs dans une émission qui
s'appelle panorama sur france culture et
vous page 12 du bouquin sur dès le début
vous dites attention je ne suis pas
renaud camus je suis pire donc via les
directs hausse dans la provoc
pourquoi parce que d'abord moi je peux
me le permettre parce que je suis juif
donc oui c'est plus facile pour attaquer
les juges quand on est juste enfin on a
le droit d'attaquer juste que quand on
est juif donc 3 - le risque s'est classé
ça et c'est vrai d'ailleurs page 102
votre bouquin vous donnez votre cv
complet est effectivement vous donnez
votre vrai nom william barranais
expliqué que vous êtes juifs sépharades
et ashkenazes mélanger et donc le fait
d'être juif vous autorise à dire ce que
vous dites page 26 avouait toute une
litanie sur kilmer kilmer kilmer j'en
attends qu il marre on attend qu'il en
attend patiemment n'attend que ça se
passe le fait des juifs vous autorise à
surenchérir sur renaud camus
ben moi je fais pas exactement pour les
mêmes raisons serre que lui il attaque
les juifs en disant ils sont pas
françaises n'ont pas de racines et moi
je dis les juifs en ce moment ont une
espèce de magistère moral sur la france
et puis je pense l'occident en général
mais bon beaucoup la france voilà
restera à la france parce qu'on leur
demande de sauver le judéo christianisme
si vous voulez dans la mesure où le
christianisme s'est discrédité c'est
vrai que plus personne là l'église à
part les gens de plus de 60 ans c'est ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure vous
disiez tout à l'heure avec des vieux je
suis pas là pour polémiquer
pourquoi pardon je vois pas pourquoi
vous parlez pas de polémiquer avec vous
je souhaiterais continuer parce que
devrait continuer à raconter mon tour et
le prouve en masse au point commun
d'accord mais enfin vous dit que les
juifs exerce aujourd'hui en occident à
magistère moral parce qu'on leur demande
de sauver le judéo-christianisme parce
que le christianisme s'est discréditée
ouais oui je vous vois pas en quoi
m'enfin bon y sont
xi s'est discréditée au sens où plus
personne n'a envie de faire ce que fait
le pape s'est dit alors à les y aller
alors énorme expliqué votre page
calmement mais c'est paramount est ce un
peu c'est un constat quoi je vous la
parodier kg j ai envie de dire non à ce
que je constate c'est que les gens les
plus intéressants dans dans je vais être
horrible mais qui ont moins de 35 ans
ils vont pas l'église ils vont pas aux
jmj
ils vont plutôt en rêve et en boîte de
nuit voilà les deux ça elle est non il
n'ya pas les 2 avec 2 millions de
géorgie est logique mais c'est dans les
règles et dans le genre qui devrait
prendre d ecstasy au lieu de prendre des
hosties effective pourquoi devoir parce
que l'ecstasy ce traître a très bien
mais pas terrorisme là dessus les chais
la liberté au jour bien jean pas l'air
d'accord les jeunes dernier ils
connaissent rien et bien on continue
c'est quand balladur par la drac j'avais
vu quand même ce balladur il a un
magistère moral en lui pour le coup donc
dans ce cv qui est pas sans votre
bouquin vous donnez votre date de
naissance 1965
vous parlez de votre homosexualité vous
parlez des livres que vous avez écrit
alors pourquoi je comprends pas avant
qu'on vous racontiez votre vie quand
vous donniez votre cv
vous disiez que vous avez fait l'ena ce
qui est pas mal et que après vous avez
été juge
pourquoi dans ce cv là vous oubliez ça
vous le vous le rayer de votre vie cette
période l'ena juge administratif
faudrait élever des mâts différent
raconte que tu as été à l'ena je me suis
dimanche de garder ça pour la prochaine
fois ouais non parce que vous avez fait
le concours général sciences po l'ena
quand même c'est pas mal j'ai été juge à
tahiti parce qu'à l'époque je déclare
vous étiez séropositifs vous êtes décidé
de fuir paris et ça d'un seul coup c'est
ça ne fait plus partie de votre
biographie bien à part ça le cv quand
même juste sur un certain nombre de
points
vous habitez le marais pour vous pouvez
pas habiter dans et et rolande vous êtes
obligés d'habiter dans le
dans le ghetto ben c'est pas loin de mon
travail à pied si vous voulez être que
quand même déjà un avantage
et à part ça je trouve que ouais quand
on rentre dans le marais aux convois des
pda moi je me dis voilà c'est y est
c'est des gens qui vivent et ailleurs je
le sens - quoi bon ça que ça paie des
sna plus chez les hétéros ben jeu
consiste à aller pdl parce que tout le
monde sait qu'ils baissent beaucoup plus
quoi déjà et c'est quand même très
important dans la vie quoi le plaisir
nous nous impliquions alors vous êtes
dont vous dites que vous êtes éditeur
écrivain et 18 mille francs par mois et
alors maintenant revenons-en au fond du
bouquin vous dites c'est votre thèse
vous dites on se croit libre c'est faux
il ya toujours des oppresseurs et des
opprimés
il ya toujours des bourreaux et des
victimes le monde est toujours homophobe
raciste patriarcale sexistes autoritaire
family ariste théocratique classiste et
c'est donc finalement pour vous
entourent 10,68 a permis une certaine
libéralisation de la société extérieure
pour vous si rien n'a changé en fait non
non non je pense qu'on on a avancé mais
je pense qu'il ya eu un énorme retour en
arrière et et on sait très bien il ya
des dates
moi je pense que la cassure elle s'est
passé en 1975 quand giscard a remonté
les champs elysées en pull je crois que
la plante pull pour montrer qu'il était
cool et en fait tout le long des
champs-elysées il y avait des films
pornos aillent tous partout et donc
toutes les télés ont montré le défilé du
14 juillet avec le président de la
république et suce moi pour ma
trimouille et aux pénétrations pareil
contre ou sur coup parfait maintenant
c'est choquant
écoutez ça quand même
chalon
et alors voilà et bah ça a donné lieu à
une espèce de levée de boucliers de
l'ordre moral c'est-à-dire le bon je
sais pas quand le lendemain à
l'assemblée
la droite et la gauche puritaine de
l'époque se sont alliés pour dire on
peut pas permettre aux français d'être
libres 1 qu'ils arrêtent ils vont tous
voir des films où il ya des actes
sexuels que l'église chrétienne nous a
dit qu'il fallait pas faire donc on va
mettre fin à tout ça et on va voter une
loi 75 pour vous c'est là bas le retour
en arrière c'est le début de ses débuts
tout ce qu'on est en train de voir finir
maintenant parce que je pense que là on
va vers autre chose
non mais il a choisi un créneau provoc
je vais pas les décors ouais ouais j'ai
rien à dire mais alors votre bouquin
vous faites état de vos combats habituel
usage récréatif des drogues donc on y
arrivera où il faut vous 18 ans de
dépénaliser donc la gauche ne légalise
pas la drogue
toutes les drogues il n'y a pas de
gauche on sait ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement je sais pas mais je peux
toujours attendre ouais usage récréatif
des drogues dérèglement des sens
alors vous dites tout le monde a envie
de se faire attacher fister godet
fouetter partouzer bouffer du sperme
mais les gens ne le font pas parce
qu'ils ont peur
oui ça c'est l'évidence mais c'est pas
du tout ne s'est pas du tout
mais si c'est pas du tout de dérèglement
des sens qu'il s'agissait simplement de
d'expérimenter la vie ouais surtout faut
expérimenter la vie voilà la plupart du
temps ne permet pas parce qu'on a été
dressé depuis tout petit après ce qu'on
nous dit c'est à dire pas jouer avec son
caca et tous ces trucs là déjà ça
commence mal à partir de ce moment-là
entend j'en dirais ardisson l'hiver a
pas la grille et je vais avoir la grippe
pour vraiment expérimenté la vie ouais
c'est ça que vous ferez mais il faut que
vous l'avez expérimenté vous continuez à
le faire vous aimez ça au nom justement
me vient de rien de temps quoi messi
mais je suis très content d'avoir fait
donc là vous avez tous fait là attaché
système godet fouetter par tous et vous
faites du sperme d'étouffer dépendance
c'est ce que disait alain laborde et de
gamme à un moment ça devient un peu
comme une drogue non non les dépendances
d'une sexualité exacerbée
non ça ne devient pas comme une drogue
c'était comme une drogue oui c'était
comme une drogue et je m'en suis libéré
oui ça va mieux là ben phu et enfin t'as
pas l'air
[Applaudissements]
alors mon père avec mon père en même
temps il a fait l'ena
moi je trouve ces deux énarques les plus
sympas que je connais qu'on a d'autres
qui sont moins drôle
voilà c'est quand même pour un mec qui a
fait l'ena ou qu'il a bien sûr mais au
final celui de mon roman est beaucoup
plus uni c'est vrai autre combat de
guillaume dustan baiser sans capote oui
oui alors vous vous êtes séropositif
vous baiser entre séropositifs au moins
quand même si j'aimerais bien mais ma
personne veut coucher avec moi parce que
j'ai trop connu maintenant alors ça va
être très embarrassant mais marquez
danger là pourquoi parce que pourquoi
parce que c'est une façon attendait
c'est intéressant ça c'est une façon de
punir votre célébrité
il est tellement connu pareil pour
l'emmerder je vais pas couché avec lui
c'est ça bah ouais ouais
dans cette histoire de baiser sans
capote là guillaume c'est quand même
important je veux dire vous êtes
d'accord avec jean paul ii vous me direz
d'une certaine façon mais sauf sur vous
c'est quand même là il ya un côté un
paradoxe
il ya un côté standard mais il ya quand
même un côté cyril collard quand même
quelque part c'est à dire c'est un
revolver que vous avez entre les jambes
quand même non c'est un revolver que
j'ai entre les gens tout le monde a un
revolver dans la tête un coup moi je
veux dire la vie c'est ce à quoi s'est
il ya un risque de violence
c'est vrai et et moi ce que je demande
c'est simplement qu'on m'empêche pas
d'avoir une sexualité normale avec des
gens qui ont le même statut sérologique
que moi et vous dites d'ailleurs le coup
de génie divin ça reprend le titre de
votre livre c'est d'avoir mis ce
problème de de baiser sans capote que
vous appelez le bareback sur le plan
philosophique c'est à dire que
finalement c'est la responsabilité
j'ai commencé comme c'est comme un
devoir du bacon philo quoi moi ce que
j'ai dit c'est que
on est responsable pour soi et pas pour
les autres et ouais c'est un point
important parce que c'est effectivement
le contraire de ce que plein de gens
essaient de nous faire croire et je
pense que c'est très dangereux de penser
qu'on est responsable pour les autres
parce que à partir du moment où pour ça
on s'occupe plus d'eux soir et puis se
passe plus rien quoi ou quoi que les
responsables pour soi et pour les autres
et pour le nom n'est pas responsable
non on peut les écouter les autres on
peut les écouter
puis c'est vraiment la seule chose qu'on
peut faire c'est déjà pas mal le fait
beaucoup moins là on a un point d'accord
un peu beaucoup
est-ce que alors pour être beaucoup plus
prosaïque est ce que il n'ya pas qu'on
vous baiser sans capote avec des
séropositifs sk par un risque de
surinfection ça c'est ce qu'on nous
raconte toujours pas prouvé
ouais et puis et puis même s'il y avait
un risque de surinfection
on a droit de prendre ce risque ouais
alors quand vous dites guillaume dustan
en toute façon on meurt pas du sida
moi je suis séropositif depuis neuf ans
je suis toujours là j'ai rien pris
jusqu'à récemment une bithérapie et tout
ça c'est dans la tête que j'ai quand
même pas peur de donner un exemple un
peu négatif un medef
je disais ça quand j'étais fou je disais
ça quand je prends tu sais non mais
sérieusement on est rassuré aujourd'hui
on voit que vous n'êtes plus fous n'est
ce pas je ne sais pas
ouais voilà un nom jsa quand je pensais
que j'allais à y passer parce que
j'étais invincible un gros de lure quoi
mais je pense que dans des situations
extrêmement violente gens deviennent
fous quand c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
fous dans la vie c'est extrêmement il a
alors là vous savez comment ça va ça va
je prends des médicaments je pense que
je vais mourir en disant c'est pas très
agréable mais bon j'ai travaillé
beaucoup peut-être que dans dix ans de
réinventer un remède were sa mort a pas
empêchés d'être effet un bal
bon alors vous êtes vous êtes favorable
à l'euthanasie
oui oui bien sûr évidemment non je pense
que c'est la moindre des libertés que de
choisir sa mort quoi la position de
l'église sur l'euthanasie c'est quoi ces
c'est de développer les soins palliatifs
pour éviter la souffrance sa souffrance
mais paraît donc triche à souffrir par
les eaux si elle déjà c'est sûr non on
peut s'offrir si c'est un choix
personnel et délicieux vin s'il
souhaitait pas par le subir pour les
bébés et moi j'ai été très impressionné
parce que ma mère est morte il ya un an
elle a eu six mois de soins palliatifs
et nous l'avons accompagné frères et
soeurs chaque jour et je trouve cette
option d étape extraordinaire pour
connaître la personne jusqu'au bout bien
alors là où c'est plus grave quand même
guillaume page 274 vous prenez
l'eugénisme pour booster l'intelligence
il faut éliminer les gens quand un
quotient intellectuel inférieur à 180
sinon on restera toujours des singes
ouais c'est vrai nom mais je dis pas
qu'il faut les éliminer maintenant l'un
de ceux qui sont d'accord ça me rassure
parce que c'est comme les fonctionnaires
voulaient s'engager d'accord sur la
maintenant on la garde
oui d'accord sur les fonctionnaires on
attend qu'ils partent à la retraite quoi
c'est ça c'est la même chose que qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec ceux qui vont naître
et qui ont moins de 180 de traction
intégrale c'est pareil on sera obligé de
les garder mais ce nom mais là où ça ou
c'est un vrai débat c'est que ces
mouches telle intelligence ouais ouais
si on peut faut mettre le paquet ont
génétiquement pour améliorer l'espèce
humaine c'est vrai qu'on est content
parce que ça se voit les gens sont
manipulés géré les gens sont des gogos
un gens sont des victimes
moi ça me fatigue un en-avant son avance
alors vous en prenez à tout le monde
dans ce bouquin triple alors ce qui m'a
le plus surpris même au [ __ ] vous dit en
fait les gens veulent toujours passer
pour le [ __ ] actif comme suit qui se
répand culé parce que finalement le fait
de passes faire [ __ ] des trains p des
actifs
ça rend un peu moins [ __ ] donc c'est mieux
que j'ai pas l'injure de base c'est quoi
c'est quand même [ __ ] ouais non moi je
suis pour qu'on criminalise les injures
homophobes
oui bien sûr j bâlois quand même un brin
tant mieux parce que moi j'en ai marre
de vivre dans un monde où j'entends paix
d [ __ ] tout le temps quand je me sens
visé
cela m'énerve or dit l'actif est mis en
valeur alors que le passif il est
considéré comme une [ __ ] basse et
l'homme il est mis en valeur et la femme
qu'ils considéraient comme un oui la
main comme dans la demeure d'un dock
servir ça veut dire qu'il ya un machisme
homo finalement ce que je dis c'est que
les rapports de pouvoir dans l'humanité
changeront pas tant que les hommes
vivront pas leur homosexualité naturel
et que donc ils se feront pas [ __ ] par
d'autres messieurs comme eux parce que
ce jour-là ils comprendront les phares
il ne méprisons plus voilà c'est tout
vous ne trouvez pas que votre blog est
un peu exhibitionniste quoi passer des
choses que j'entends confession en
confidence mais quel intérêt
attendez aujourd'hui est de 2,10 la
vigne la vie on la partage pas comme ça
n'importe comment
cependant je pense qu a pas de raison
que les choses doivent être dites et que
ce qui fait la force de cette émission
c'est justement qu'on parle de tout tout
à fait librement tous est intéressant
dans une télévision qui est très con
passé qui est très fermée sur elle même
je trouve intéressant au moins une fois
par semaine le samedi soir de pouvoir
tout dire je n'aurais je ne crains pas
le monde d'accord et je ne crains pas
qu'on m'enlève d un monopole de
confidences
oui mais ma question que je me pose si
elle veut dire est-ce qu'on peut tout
dire en public quoi ça
mais une question se pose au public
d'ailleurs oui oui je pense y jouer mais
bon voilà c'est mon j'y réfléchirai
c'est mon côté 68 peut-être alors page
254 et pour finir vous défendez la femme
car vous dit j'étais impuissant pendant
un an j'ai donc passif pendant un an et
c'est un sale boulot de ce fait remettre
son pouvoir rendre la pareille donc
seulement j'étais assez féministe d'une
certaine façon et pas puni ce que moi
ouais
d'ailleurs ça se moque se retrouvent
ouais ça se voit que ce que je porte les
stigmates de la féminité je veux dire
c'est christ et compère away le
blasphème est pas
guillaume dustan je pense que pour vous
une interview psi serait assez bienvenu
en la bouche pendant le signal on ne
bouge pas pendant qu' on ne bouge pas
pendant le digger
[Applaudissements]
bien l'interview psy est ce que vous
êtes mytho j'ai peur vous soyez tous là
j'ai peur j'ai peur que vous ayez j'ai
peur que vous ayez une croix dans chaque
cas allez courage bah non non je veux
mais c'est plutôt non je suis vraiment
le meilleur écrivain de france voilà
donc germé galop vous êtes les galops
vous le reconnaissez
non j'ai le sens de ma valeur d'accord
est ce que vous êtes parano extrêmement
mais je pense que j'ai vraiment de
bonnes raisons de l'être
pourquoi parce que tout le monde n'en
veut pas du tout cas pas moi sorti est
ce que vous êtes schizo bas c'était un
peu quand je me rends compte c'est trop
tard est ce que vous êtes maso oui non
vous n'avez pas souffrir non gelée était
cliniquement 1
mais je suis plus quoi parce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé
c'est très difficile à soigner est ce
que vous êtes sado depuis que je suis
plus masos chez des opportunités pour
l'être et j'essaie de résister je m'en
passe vous êtes saudeau oui évidemment
est ce que vous êtes rocco banon
malheureuse gros lolos non j'aimerais
lire parce que les pdg les oreilles mon
père mais machin je suis bien refoulé
c'est à dire que
voilà c'est là que depuis qu'elles s'y
là comme je trouve que c'est vraiment
trop trop trop trop lourd pour moi de
coucher avec une femme parce que c'est
risqué magna
j'ai plus jamais nos relations avec les
femmes
alors que s'il n'y avait pas ça je pense
que ça m'arriverait temps dont vous
pourriez être gros lolos en fait ouais
le vibro j'ai fait ça depuis des années
triaud moi j'aime plus tout cas très
plus géronto j'ai regardé le soir avec
moi exhibo sens de la mode c est ce que
vous êtes de sa mode est ce que vous
êtes un travelo contin flottage si vous
êtes travelo non est ce que vous êtes
adamo oui complètement
bah il est là
cette semaine
pas toutes les semaines adamo de temps
en temps vous l'aurez de temps en temps
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou